Joe Mosnier: Today is Wednesday, April 27,
2011.
We're in Atlanta, Georgia, at the Artmore
Hotel in midtown Atlanta, with Ms. Jamila
Jones, um, to conduct an oral history for
the Smithsonian's National Museum of African
American History and Culture project entitled
“The Civil Rights History Project.”
My name is Joe Mosnier of the Southern Oral
History Program at UNC-Chapel Hill, and our
videographer is Mr. John Bishop.
Ms. Jones, good morning.
Thanks so much for sitting down.
Jamila Jones: Good morning -
JM: Appreciate -
JJ: And thank you for having me.
JM: Appreciate your effort to get up with
us, um, during this Atlanta visit.
It's really nice to see you.
Thank you.
Um, let me start today, um, as we enter into,
enter into a conversation about, um, your
work in the Southern Freedom Movement, um,
in the '50s, '60s, and even thereafter, um,
talk a little bit about your family, starting
with that.
[Coughing in background].
Can you tell me a little bit about growing
up in, um, in Montgomery and your family,
your parents, and ?
JJ: Okay.
I lived with a mother and a grandmother.
Um, I grew up with a sibling, my sister, Doris
Crenshaw, and a brother, a little younger,
about ten years younger, John Allen McCloud.
And I guess key to the Movement is the fact
that my sister and I rode the Montgomery bus
line.
So, we experienced on a daily basis during
school the harassment that came from the,
uh, bus driver.
Uh, and so, I guess that inspired us, or it
was something in us that, uh, made us relate
to, of course, the Montgomery bus boycott.
JM: Can you talk a little bit about, um, how
you came to know, um, Ms. [Rosa] Parks and
to join the youth chapter of the local NAACP?
JJ: Uh, yes.
In fact, my sister was the one who introduced
me to Mrs. Parks, uh, as we joined the NAA
youth group, NAACP youth group.
Uh, my sister was the vice-president; I was
just a member of that group.
Uh, she would have us into her home.
We would sit on the floor.
And she'd give us bits and pieces about life,
actually.
And people ask quite often if I remember things
that she said, and I do not.
Uh, but I know she read from, uh, papers,
from the, uh, national office of the NAACP.
And she taught us, uh, that we were important
- I can remember that - and that, uh, it was
key that we, uh, learn our rights, and that,
uh, voting was an important aspect of, uh,
our lives.
And I can just remember those things about
the conversations that she had with us.
And she also taught us that, uh, it was important
to carry yourself in a good, responsible,
uh, way.
Uh, after we would meet, she would give us,
uh, Kool-Aid and cookies.
JM: [Laughs]
JB: Joe, can we pause for a sec?
JM: Certainly.
[Recording stops and then resumes]
JB: We're on.
JM: Uh, Ms. Jones, you mentioned your sister,
Doris Crenshaw.
Can you talk a little bit about her?
You mentioned she was vice-president, and
just describe her a little bit.
JJ: Yeah, she was like a leader of the bunch.
And whatever she did, basically, I did.
Uh, there was, uh, a difference in us, in
that I was, uh, mostly interested in the music
portion of things that happened, and she was
more of the leadership-fighter type, uh, movement
person.
But, uh, she somehow had interest from a very
young age in, uh, rights and what was right
for you.
And she led me down that path.
JM: Um-hmm.
So, you must have been about eleven years
old when the boycott began, thereabouts?
JJ: I was eleven years old when the boycott
started.
JM: Yeah.
Um, what are some of your - you know, from
this distance, what are some of your most
vivid, most central, important memories from
that experience?
JJ: [Sighs] From that experience, I know that,
um, the youth, and Mrs. Knott [?] [nb: spelling
of name uncertain] often said, had their own
[5:00] kind of individual movement, that we
kind of led ourselves around what was happening
with the Movement, in that we organized ourselves
to get across - what we called across town,
uh, when we were no longer riding the buses.
And we had to find our own way for survival.
My sister, being the leader that she was,
wouldn't allow us ever to go and get a ride.
Uh, she said we'd be taking up space from
an adult and we were going to walk.
So, the 361 days there was school, we walked.
JM: Um-hmm.
Um, when the boycott concluded and some measure
of success was realized, in some measure on
that narrow question of busing, what was your
feeling?
JJ: It was a joyous feeling, of course.
And no longer we felt that we had to take
the abuse, uh, that we had experienced on
those buses since I was six years old, because
I started to ride the bus at age six and had
done that to age eleven.
And we found our ways to survive through that.
Uh, it was piercing to see adults have to
leave, uh, the bus and go around to pay their
money, and then get off the bus and come to
the back of the, uh, bus.
Uh, I almost never had to do that, because
we were the first stop, so we always found
ourselves with a seat.
But curious as we were, there were times we
tested to see what would happen if we sat
in the front of the bus.
And we did, and, uh, then they would ask us,
of course - when one white lady got on the
bus - I can never forget her.
She had red hair, long hair, and when she
entered the bus, we would have to get up,
even though, um, there were a number of seats,
and she was the only white to get on that
bus.
So, I think that was so piercing to us that
it nev - I never forgot it.
And, uh, when the bus boycott started, of
course, that lived within me, and I knew that
I would walk three hundred and what - however
many days, actually, that, uh, it would take.
And to a six-year-old, you just basically
are so curious about why is it that we have
to get up, that often I would sit behind her
and, uh, she would choose the same seat each
time she got on the bus.
JM: This white woman?
JJ: This white, uh, woman.
I don't know her name.
I just remember her face and her red hair.
But when she got on the bus, I decided, uh,
several times to just feel her hair, to see
if I could put my little fingers, uh, on the
top of the seat to see if it was a difference.
What is the difference with her and the rest
of us?
And I did.
I would just kind of feel that hair like it
was an accident.
I don't know what I concluded from that, except
that it just gave me a feeling that, uh, I
feel she's really no different.
This hair is not so much different from ours.
And, um, that was just my little childhood
curiosity and how I answered it.
JM: Sure.
[Clears throat]
JJ: Uh, so that just that one white lady put
such, uh, curiosity in me.
And I wanted to answer that so much that I,
uh, knew that I was going to walk the length
of the time it would take for us to get to,
uh, our goal.
JM: Yeah.
Um, when and how did you start singing?
JJ: Started singing - we were, um, elementary
school students at Alabama State Laboratory
High School.
And, uh, each Friday we would have a, uh - I
would call it a talent show.
And we formed this group, uh, three girls
- uh, actually it was four of us from the
beginning - formed this group [10:00] so that
we could compete each Friday in the, uh, talent
contest.
Somehow, it was something in us that made
us want to do freedom songs.
And I can't answer today why we chose that,
because we're about the same age as, uh, Diana
Ross.
But when we went outside to practice, we practiced
freedom songs.
And that's what we would sing.
So, when the Montgomery bus boycott came - we
formed this group at, uh, around the age nine
and ten - uh, we were kind of ready.
And so because of the songs we were singing,
it lent itself to the Movement, we were asked
to come to sing at practically every tea that
was held in Montgomery.
You know, uh, during that time, they had a
lot of teas that raised money for the Movement,
as well as other things for the churches.
And they would invite us to come, and I felt
like, uh, it couldn't be a tea, or they felt
like, uh, they couldn't have a tea if we didn't
come.
So, we went all over town to teas on Sunday
to participate, and we were kind of carrying
the message of the Movement, uh, through our
songs.
And we were relevant for the time, and that's
why they called on us.
JM: So, you were - this was a group of four
girls, all eleven or twelve years old, I guess,
in that ?
JJ: We were, um -
JM: In that moment.
JJ: In that moment we were eleven.
JM: Do you remember the names of the other
girls?
JJ: I do.
It was Gladys Carter - because we formed the
group and we, uh, all through high school,
we kept the group.
Uh, Gladys Carter and Minnie Hendricks, now
McCants - we were the three girls who lasted
among the four.
Uh, we decided we were going to not only practice
at school, but we would practice at each other's
homes.
And that's how the fourth girl dropped out,
because her parents wouldn't allow her to
come each evening, or the evenings that we
had set for practice.
And thus, it became the four - three girls.
JM: Did you also - I'm sorry.
Did you also sing in church?
JJ: We did.
We would sing in church, but we mostly sang
at school at first, because, uh, we all went
to different churches.
JM: Yeah.
Which was your church?
JJ: Uh, mine was Mt. Zion A.M.E.
Zion church.
JM: Was any of the other girls, uh, at Reverend
King's church?
JJ: Uh, none of us were, uh, members -
JM: Yeah.
JJ: Of Reverend King's church.
Minnie McCants was a member of, uh, Reverend
[Ralph David] Abernathy's church.
JM: Um-hmm, um-hmm.
JJ: I was with, uh, Reverend [Solomon] Seay
[pronounces “Say”], Seay [pronounces “See”],
Seay [pronounces “Say” again], uh, who
was - had the first meeting for the Montgomery
bus boycott, uh, and he was very active.
JM: Um-hmm.
JJ: As a matter of fact, the, uh, things in
your life that cause you to - I guess the
sum total of things cause you to be what - whatever
you are in life.
And, uh, he taught each Sunday about accomplishments
they had made, uh, toward needs of the black
community, and I would hear what he had to
say.
Uh, so that was one of the influences that
I had, in terms of my life and, uh, fighting
for freedom or struggle.
JM: Yeah, yeah.
Um, let's see, you must have entered high
school around '57, fall of '57, fall of '58,
I guess?
JJ: Yeah, I finished in '62.
JM: Yeah, okay.
Um, and can you describe, um, the ? I think
in the late '50s, because at some point if,
if, um, - I've read a couple of different
accounts, but, um, one indicates that you
traveled to Highlander Folk School.
JJ: I did, but that was before high school.
It was like junior high, I think it was.
But, um, I was singing, and along with the,
uh, my sister being very active, we were selected
to go to do a kind of like a cultural exchange
in terms of our music.
We would share the kind of songs that we were
singing, and Guy Carawan headed up that, um
- the workshops.
And people from around the world, actually,
because we met people from Africa there, uh,
would share [15:00] the kind of movement songs
they were doing.
It was because we - our repertoire of songs,
of freedom songs, were, uh, great and extensive
that he asked that we come to, uh, uh, New
York to do, uh, freedom songs to raise money
for the Movement, Southern Movement.
And that's how we got to Carnegie Hall with
Reverend [Fred] Shuttlesworth and others,
to do that, uh, fundraiser.
And from that came one of the first albums
of civil rights songs, uh, to be, uh, used,
uh, for fundraising and that kind of thing.
And so, we were, uh, the Montgomery Trio.
We did not have a name.
We went all over Montgomery before that time,
never thought about a name.
Uh, they would just say, “The girls,”
“We gotta have the girls,” or “The girls
this -.” And when we got there, uh, they
said, “For this album, you've got to have
a name.”
So, we debated and debated about what could
be our name and came up with the Montgomery
Gospel Trio.
JM: Um-hmm, um-hmm.
How old were you at that time when you went
to New York?
JJ: I want to say I - you know, around sixteen.
JM: Yeah.
Just into high school?
JJ: Yes.
JM: [Coughs] Um, can you, can you talk me
through the - your high school years, because
obviously the Movement will shift into a very
active phase while you were in high school
-
JJ: Right.
JM: And um, uh, the, um, Freedom Singers will
come into being towards the end of your high
school years.
So, I'm interested in how you move through
those years singing, protesting, as an activist,
young activist.
JJ: Yes.
And what happened is that Montgomery - when
you have a large-scale movement like that,
uh, quite often there are a lot of wounds
that occur - so, Montgomery, um, particularly
it - adults, it, uh, the adults could not
sit down sometimes in the same room, let along
talk about [laughs] a movement.
And so, the youth were used.
So, when James Bevel and all the people came
into Montgomery - and, by the way, we did
meet James Bevel and, uh, Bernard Lafayette
- were the other group that came to, uh, do
the concert at Carnegie Hall, so we had already
met them.
But they came into Montgomery first with the,
uh, Freedom Riders.
And so, because we knew them, we had gone
to, uh, Reverend Abernathy's house and waiting
to get the cue to go pick up the Freedom Riders
as they came in, because at that time we still
active in the Movement and still singing.
And Mrs. Abernathy, uh, said, uh, “We don't
have anybody to pick them up.”
Now, a lot of adults will tell you that they
did, [laughs] but that day we stole a car.
We said, “Well, oh, we got to go, uh, find
a way to get the, uh, Freedom Riders!”
And, uh, there was a girl, her name was Antonette
Carson, and she had her license at the time,
and her fath - grandfather would leave his
car in the garage every day.
So, we schemed together and said we were going
to steal his car and go pick up the Freedom
Riders.
And we did.
But we said, “How in the world are we going
to get this car back in here?”
So, what we did was we took some chalk, school
chalk, and marked where the tires of his car
were, and took the car, picked up the Freedom
Riders, went back and put that car right in
the tracks of those marks that we had made.
And it was such an eventful day to see how
they were beaten and how they were treated,
uh, when getting off of those buses.
And we had a carload when we - when we left.
JM: Yeah, yeah.
Were you, um, yourself, uh, ever so close
to violence that you really feared for your
own personal safety?
JJ: [Sighs] It's something about youth, that
even when you have fear [20:00], and it's
something about having lived that kind of
life, that your fear is bundled, and it's
there, but it does not outweigh the need to,
uh, participate.
So that there were times when we had - we
feared, we had fear.
In fact, the night that the Freedom Riders
came in, uh, we went to the church, uh, carried
them to the church, and we were there for
the mass meeting that night.
And when we went in, there were no whites.
When we sat there a while, the church was
completely surrounded.
As far as you could see were, um, white, uh,
mostly males on horses and, uh, carrying long
guns and sitting outside, waiting on us to
come out.
And that was the night that we, in fact, spent
the night at the church.
So, it was a fearful night, but not enough
fear to stop us from doing what we needed
to do.
JM: Did you ? Sorry.
JJ: I was just going to say that, uh, Reverend,
uh, Seay said that night, uh, to me.
We were eating - some food had come in, sandwiches
and that kind of thing - and he was sitting
on the steps at the church, on the inside.
And I said, “Reverend Seay, what what are
we going to do?”
Because as far as we could see were all these
people surrounding us!
And he said, uh, “We're going to do like
the doodle bug.”
And I said, “What do you mean?”
He said, “Doodle Bug,” because he called
me Doodle Bug quite a bit, “we're going
to do like the doodle bug.”
And I was an adult before I really understood
what he was saying, but we played this game
in Montgomery, and we would sing the “Doodle
Bug Song.”
It was [begins to sing], “Back-a-back, doodle,
back, back.
Your house is on afire.
Your children's burning.
Back-a-back, doodle, back, back.”
And I had to think about it as I became an
adult, because I really didn't know at the
time what he was saying.
And I thought about how that song said, “Your
house is on afire, and you're in trouble,”
but you're going to be just like the doodle
bug.
And the doodle bug, when we were singing that
song, the doodle bug would baaack up, just
back out of, uh, the sand, and, uh, he was
so small, but as if to say, “I'm protecting
my own.”
JM: Let's pause for just - excuse me just
one sec, if we could, John.
[Recording stops and then resumes]
JB: We're back.
JM: We're back after a short break.
Can you tell me about, um - Ms. Jones, can
you tell me about the founding of the, um,
the Freedom Singers?
JJ: Well, actually, the Freedom Singers, as
you know them, I was not a part of that group.
I joined after leaving the Montgomery Trio.
But remember I went to school at Alabama State
University, so that, uh, we kept the group
- and so did, uh, the other two girls, and
so we kept the group going during the time
that we were fighting to, for voter registration
and that kind of thing.
I may have mentioned that, uh, a lot of that
was done by the youth, because a lot of adults
no longer wanted to participate for whatever
their reasons were.
Uh, so, when James Bevel and those people
came into Montgomery, they called on us to
sing before the meetings that we would have
in the rural areas, as well as in the city
of Montgomery.
So, we would travel around with them, and
we'd do the singing, um, at the churches before
the speaker would, of course, speak.
So, we kept our group, the Montgomery Trio,
going up until that time.
And, um - after which I came to Atlanta, uh,
got with Bernice Reagon.
Uh, it started, I guess - I have to back up
to say that, uh, she had asked that I participate
in the, what they called the Penny Festival.
And that's where the community and the school
- there was so much separation [25:00] that
they had formed this Penny Festival to come
together with the community to put on a performance
each year.
JM: This was here in Atlanta?
[Increased microphone noise]
JJ: Yes.
And, uh, SNCC did that.
And when Bernice Reagon asked me to participate,
we did the music for that first Penny Festival
that we would, uh, we were doing.
And, um, after, I said, “Goodness, I haven't
been singing, and this was so good to participate
in this kind of thing.”
So, myself, along with another singer that,
uh, was in the Harambee Singers, Mattie Casey,
uh, Pierce now, went to Bernice's house and
knocked on the door and said, “We'd like
to just continue to sing.
Let's continue to sing.”
And thus, uh, was started the Harambee Singers.
So, I wasn't in that, uh, freedom group singers
with Bernice, but in the Harambee Singers
with her.
JM: Let me take you back.
Tell me about - I want to ask about repertoire
and what you most liked to sing, say, in the
- early in the gospel trio in Montgomery,
later in the - when you're in college, and
then later with Harambee.
JJ: It depended on what was happening at the
time.
Uh, that determined what we would sing and
what message we would - because we learned
at Highlander that these songs not only could
carry a message for the Movement in Montgomery,
but songs carry, uh, the message of the Movement
wherever.
And that when we went to, uh, Highlander,
we would sing, and, uh, our songs, uh, “This
Little Light of Mine,” which became one
of the famous songs of the Movement.
And it's interesting to note that we were
singing that for the Movement at eleven years
old, um, and became one of the songs on the
the, uh, album that we did.
But that was one of the important songs.
“We Are Soldiers in the Army” was one
of the songs we did.
“Oh, Freedom.”
So, we were doing all of these songs at eleven
years old for the Movement, songs which later
became the bulk of songs and, uh, the basis
of the songs for that upcoming Civil Rights
Movement.
JM: [Coughs] Would you ? [Clears throat] Excuse
me.
What part did you sing?
JJ: I sang, uh, basically the melody.
JM: Um-hmm.
JJ: But we did interchange, and I'd do a lot
of the lead singing on the, uh, songs, uh,
the verse singing.
JM: Um-hmm, um-hmm.
Tell me about, um, that work, um, I think
with, um, about '66, 1966 forward, the Harambee
Singers.
Tell me about how that group evolved and,
and your work there.
JJ: I will.
Um, I do want to say a bit more about Highlander
and how our songs began to change as we, uh,
attended those workshops with Guy Carawan
and all.
If you go back to the songs, you'll see that
we were singing songs, but basically we didn't
write the songs.
There is a Montgomery song that represents
that movement that was written by one of the
professors at Alabama State, which for me
for that era was the first actual song that
was written for the movement.
And I'd like to get that in, because people
think it happened later on, but, no, right
at that time, he wrote that song.
But when we went to Highlander, we were singing
some of the songs, basically the freedom songs,
basically as they were done traditionally.
And we are traditional singers, uh, and we
would add a word in, and a verse or a line,
to represent our movement, or sometimes we
would change a line.
But we weren't actually changing whole songs
until actually we got there - to Highlander
- and saw others do it.
And then, we thought we were equipped.
We were going back then, writing songs and
doing our own, you know, version of the songs.
But we kept it traditional, in terms of how
we would sing the songs.
So, if you hear our album or any of those
things, you will see we kept, uh, the traditional
ways of, uh, doing that.
I wanted to add that [30:00] because I wanted
to give him credit for how songs changed during
the Movement and that kind of thing.
JM: [Coughs] Excuse me.
JB: What was the song that ?
JM: In particular - yeah?
JB: Yeah, what was that song that he wrote?
JM: There's one song that your -
JJ: He wrote, uh, uh, “Ain't Gonna Ride
No Bus No More.”
And it's interesting how he wrote that song,
because sometimes now when I'm singing it
or we are performing that song, people look
and say, “Did y'all say ‘hell'?”
“Yes, that's the way he wrote the song,”
because he wrote it from a traditional song
that, um, I think that that song is “Ain't
Gonna Rain No More.”
And in that song it says, “How in the hell
do the old folk know it ain't gonna rain no
more?”
And he said, “How in the hell don't the
white folk know we ain't gonna ride them buses
no more?”
JM: [Laughs] I have read two different accounts
for how, uh, you are credited with adding
a very important verse to “We Shall Overcome.”
Can you share that story with us?
[Sound levels vary while Ms. Jones is speaking]
JJ: You know what?
I don't know how much light I can, uh, place
on that, because you have to remember that
I was at Highlander when I was probably fourteen
years old.
And we weren't thinking at the time, “Oh,
I said this; I did this.”
That was not upon our minds.
So that I can remember that, uh, when we went
to Highlander, uh, we had workshops to prepare
us for different things that we would face.
And one of the things that Reverend Seay,
who drove us there, uh, said to us is that
we are going to leave by night.
And the reason for that is when you get into
Monteagle, Tennessee, the population of, uh,
blacks is - the population is just one, and
that was Septima Clark.
And so, to go in by night, we would not be
noticed as we would go in.
So we went there by night, and we came back
by night.
But one of the things that happened when we
were there is the policemen from the city
came in.
Uh, we were having a movie, I believe, that
night, or a song fest, and, uh, they came
in.
They turned out all the lights - from the
city they turned them out.
So, we were in complete darkness that night.
And, um, we could not see each other.
We didn't know where - I didn't know where
my sister was.
I didn't know where Minnie was.
We were just there - wherever we were at the
time when the lights went out - careful - that's
where we sat.
And so, all these policemen came in.
And all we could see, basically, is the billy
club, uh, waving, and the, uh, the butts of
their guns - you could see it shining on their
holster.
Uh, and they told us to sit, you know, of
course, uh, stay seated, or be quiet, or what
have you.
And something [pause] said, [begins singing
slowly] “We are not afraid,” and everybody
started singing, [singing] “We are not -,” and
you could hear people come in.
My sister, who is not a singer, I knew she
was safe, because I heard her little out-of-tune
voice coming in.
And I could hear Minnie's bass come in, about,
“We are not afraid.”
And we got louder and louder with singing
that verse, until one of the policemen came
and he said to me, “If you have to sing,”
and he was actually shaking, “do you have
to sing so loud?”
And I could not believe it.
Here these people had all the guns, the billy
clubs, the power, we thought [pause] and he
was asking me, with a shake, if I would not
sing so loud.
And it was that time that I really understood
the power of our move—of our music, [35:00]
how powerful it was that this - it unnerved
him so much that he had to come and ask that
I not sing so loud.
And I can just tell you that I got louder
and louder.
And somehow even the nature out there in that
darkness, because everywhere was dark, but
it looked like our voices blended that night
to the point of complete harmony and beauty.
And from then on, I knew exactly how powerful
our songs were.
JM: Can you remember singing in a - can you
tell a story about singing in a particular
place that really stands - in a moment and
a place that really stands out in your memory,
very vividly?
JJ: Now, that stands out.
JM: I'm sure there are lots.
JJ: But - there are a number of them, but
I can say that we were in Montgomery.
I was in college at the time.
And we were, uh, King was going to take us
from his church - uh, he was no longer living
there at the time, but he had come back for
- I can't even remember what the Movement
was all about.
But we were going to march to the, uh, capital
in Montgomery.
And as we, uh - we got to the top of the steps,
and you saw all of these white folks.
The people had - they had taken - the males
had taken off their shirts, and they were
just bare-chested, standing up there with,
uh, rifles and riding their horses.
And, again, I saw - I faced these horses coming
down on you.
And when I got to the top of the steps, it
made me sing [laughs] that verse again, “We
are not afraid,” and we started singing
it.
Now, I can tell you that my knees were actually
shaking that day when I looked out to see
all of them, and we were going to, you know,
try to march to the—to the capital.
But singing that song and that verse helped
to kind of steady those knees at that time.
And I can remember that particular verse at
that time and that particular, uh, movement.
JM: Tell me - let's just, um, shift for just
a moment.
And I'm interested in your experience in college.
Can you describe your ?
JJ: Well, those college days were spent, as
I said - SCLC had formed and sent James Bevel
and James Orange into Montgomery.
And what we worked on at the time was, uh,
voter registration again, even though I had
handled voter registration at eleven, uh,
twelve years old with Mrs. [Idessa] Williams
in Montgomery, and, um, uh, during my high
school days we just continued that whole thing
of, uh, going to Kings Hill.
We ventured out into other places besides
Montgomery, because Montgomery was so tight
at that time, after having gone through that
Montgomery bus boycott.
And the other thing we were working on was,
uh, sit-ins.
And so, we would go to the church and plan,
as youth, with James Bevel and James Orange,
how we were going to go to the five and ten
cent stores.
And, um, they taught us at that time - they
had gone through training sessions on how
to protect your head and that kind of thing,
and what happens if someone spits on you.
And, uh, really, they taught us nonviolence
to a great extent.
And so, that's - those were the kinds of things
that we worked on.
But let me just go back and say, at twelve
years old, uh, Mrs. Rosa Parks and Mrs. Williams,
uh, taught us how to fill out twenty-seven-page
questionnaires, uh, so that we could go into
the homes of adults and teach them how to
fill out those questions, uh, to become voters.
That's what you had to do at the time, just
silly, stupid kinds of questions.
We had to learn the preamble to the Constitution.
But they set us in a little shop, uh, behind
her house.
She was, uh, a hairdresser, and we would - the
youth would go in there, sit on the floor,
and we'd learn how to fill out these - at
eleven - fill out these, uh, and answer the
questions.
And, uh, we would knock on doors and [40:00]
teach adults how to fill it out.
JM: Yeah, yeah.
By the mid '60s, the Civil Rights Act has
passed, the Voting Rights Act has passed,
but there's been tremendous violence and difficulty,
and I'm thinking about the founding of the
Harambee Singers.
And, um, how did your perspective at that
time, say '66 maybe, compare to your perspective
earlier in the '60s?
Were you - what was your overall sense and
feeling about the Movement at that point and
its progress and its challenges and its difficulties?
JJ: Um-hmm.
Uh, personally, I started paying more attention
to I guess what we call Black Power and the
Pan-Africanist movement.
And so, the songs that we performed as Harambee
Singers were what we would call very radical
type songs, uh, “Move On Over Or We'll Move
On Over You,” and the songs took a different
tone and became also international.
We were very in tune to our heritage at the
time and, um, as I said, Black Power.
And, uh, so, when we went, our hair was Afroed
and this kind of thing, and our songs took
on some of that same mentality at the time.
So, the Harambee Singers' songs - we never
did the songs that, uh, were performed by
the Montgomery Trio, but in fact, uh, Pan-Africanist
type songs.
JM: Can you tell me a little bit more about
[clears throat] - excuse me - about the group's
repertoire?
JJ: Um, in terms of the songs, um, “Hands
Off Nkrumah” was one of the songs that we
did, because at that time, as I say, we had
a Pan-Africanist perspective to what we were
doing in song.
And, uh, so, that was important to us as,
uh, the Movement was going on in Ghana.
We, uh, did do that song of “Hands off Nkrumah,
uh, that's what the people say, ‘Hands off
Nkrumah.'”
Uh, and, uh, we talked about the CIA in the
song.
So, we start attacking other elements of not
only, uh, this country, but the world, in
what was happening.
JB: Can we pause for a sec?
JM: Sure.
[Recording stops and then resumes]
JJ: I go into things, uh - there are other
elements or things that come to mind.
JM: Sure, sure.
JJ: You know, but, um - unless you have some
questions about the things - uh, want me to
expand on things that have already been said,
I'll just kind of think, you know - don't
you ?
JM: We've done pretty well, is that what you're
saying?
JJ: I would think.
[Laughs]
JM: Yeah.
No, I think it's been fabulous.
JJ: [Laughs]
JM: I did want to - I did want to maybe go
back -
JJ: Um-hmm.
JM: And just ask about, um - the question
of whether or not, uh, your mother and your
grandmother ever had to try to pull you and
your sister and brother back a little bit
out of fear for your safety.
Did they - is that a good question - because
that's just a natural ?
JJ: Yeah, but I'll start with our community
and just say [clears throat] -
JM: Okay.
[Recording stops and then resumes]
JB: We're on.
JM: We're on, okay.
We've had a short break and we're going to
come back and talk a little bit more about
family and community.
JJ: Yes.
Um, our community were, uh, was filled with
people who had participated in struggle in
some type way.
Um, we had Flora Grant, who had one of the
large debits in, uh, Atlanta Life Insurance
Company and who kept herself close to movement
things that's happening in the community,
who would come to my home and sit with my
mother to talk about those things, as I sat
under the table, and they played cards.
But, uh - and I would hear a lot at that time,
because she was very knowledgeable as to the
kind of current things happening in the Montgomery
community.
So, we had Flora Grant.
And we had the young lady who wrote, uh, “See
How They Run.”
Uh, we had Sullivan Rogers, who was one of
the first black jockeys, and, uh, we saw him
train his horses, and he would tell us stories.
Uh, and we had my aunt, who lived with us,
and her name - we called her Bessie B. [45:00]
Now, Bessie B was the storyteller in my family,
and she would tell us about all kinds of struggles.
And the story that I remember from her was
about Old John.
And when she talked about Old John, she said
that he, uh, worked hard from sunup to sundown
to take care of his family, of the family,
but at the end of the day or the week, he
had no meat, he, uh, had very little food,
and it would bother him so much that he had
taken care and raised the food for his, uh,
owner, uh, as he sharecropped, but, uh, he
could not pay his bill at the end of the week.
And so, Old John found ways to, uh, every
so often, get his family a chicken.
And she told us the story of how John trained
his younger son to come with him, as they
would get one chicken out of - from the white
folks' chicken coop.
And he said, “John, this night I'm going
to teach you how to pries.
And you're going to pries the chicken coop
while I go under and get this one chicken,”
because there's something about black families
that told them that they were to get whatever
it was to survive, but not more than that.
And so, he would get this one chicken, uh,
for his family.
So, he carried, uh - Little John, I guess,
uh, was about the age of twelve, I think she
told us - and they would get this long stick
to pry up the chicken coop.
And, um, this particular night he was saying,
“Pries, boy!
Pries, boy,” as John was shaking and almost
to drop the chicken coop, uh, before John
could get the, uh, chicken from the chicken
coop.
And he did.
“Pries, boy!
Pries!”
And my aunt would just shake all over in her
voice as she was telling the story about “Pries,
boy!”
And, um, he dropped the chicken coop, could
no longer hold it.
And John said, “Run, boy!
Go tell your mama you done drop - uh, you
done lost your pries!”
And so, later on in life, uh, from that story
- I'll never forget, uh, that John could not
feed his family working from sunup to sundown.
Something in my head did not, you know, set
well with the fact that he couldn't feed his
family in that story.
So, later on, I wrote a song that says, [begins
singing] “Pries, boy!
Pries, boy!
Pries, boy, pries!
Run fast!
Go tell your mama John done lost his pries.”
JM: Mmm, that's beautiful.
JJ: So, the people in the community - and
as I say and tell young people, the sum total
of what you select to do in life will determine
your life.
And I think it was the sum total of these
people and their impact on our lives that
kept us even today, as I sit here, sixty-seven
years old, uh, still involved in, uh, fighting
for freedom.
So, it is those kind of things, and I tell,
uh, even seniors today - I work with seniors
- that we have to keep ourselves close to
the young people, because it's the older people
that had this impact in our lives that caused
us to be the people that we are today.
JM: I really want to thank you for joining
us this morning.
It's been a real pleasure to be with you.
Thank you.